yes that is planet Earth yes you are on
a spaceship I play dr. rush dr. rush is
the the lead scientist against in this
expedition which we're supposed to take
this this team initially to this Icarus
planet what happens there as you come
under attack then ever choice did he go
home else or did he go to the ninth
Chevron which is kind of like the Holy
Grail in the Stargate world and Russia's
this couple that we of doing that so he
dials the ninth Chevron takes them then
they think they're going to be another
world basically but in fact there are
none of us patient we're under attack
I need to get these people out of here
probably we don't know what's on the
other side once they get all grateful to
rush for saving the life obviously
attack on the base this is OK when did
we go home that was the reason why one
of the major reasons why I accepted the
script I love that notion
I thought wise getting on in this month
and leaders Monica for these are the
wall
make no mistake we are going to make it
home I was looking for something
different to be honest be something
definite to do I did that better I've
enjoyed doing some television in the
States
six seven years ago I played Hitler for
CBS that was a great experience in fact
the normal thing I talk about the mobile
estate in the British film industry I
mean it's not good it's not good at all
you know about making less and less and
less films I got fair dr. view on SP I
was getting fed up I made two movies
about eighteen months ago one called
summer and one called I know you know
and my opinion I think these are the
best performances ever ever getting very
very very proud to these funds and have
been seen by a bit twenty people I want
to go somewhere where I can something's
going to be seen at least get away from
all do something entirely different
this is entirely different we are going
to have to be tough
you